[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
und das sind einige unserer themen heute
ich kann kanzler eine woche noch bleiben
bernburg laschet und scholz um die
vielen unentschlossenen im land von sich
zu überzeugen
zur arbeit nur noch mit gesundheitspass
in italien müssen alle beschäftigten
künftig nachweisen dass sie entweder
geimpft oder getestet sind
obenrum und feier laune bei der
verleihung des deutschen fernsehpreises
gehören hape kerkeling und markus lanz
zu den großen gewinnern des abends
so spannend war es selten eine gute
woche vor der bundestagswahl ist völlig
offen wer deutschland künftig regiert
nach dem aktuellen politbarometer ist
eine koalition mit einem
spd-bundeskanzler scholz genauso möglich
wie eine mit einem cdu bundeskanzler
laschet das erhöht den druck auf den
letzten metern noch mal alles zu geben
der bericht von stefan leifert beginnt
in bayern wo heute der unionskandidat
erwartet wurde
bevor armin laschet kommt hat markus
söder noch einen termin mit figuren von
star wars gute gelegenheit höhere
instanzen zu beschwören möge die macht
mit uns
im kampf um die macht in berlin ist es
eng geworden für die union der csu chef
eröffnet in nürnberg ein neues museum
für zukunft welche zukunft sicht der
union noch eröffnet hängt nun vor allem
von ihm ab armin laschet wird heute
durch bayern nicht immer war das in
letzter zeit einen besuch bei freunden
und cdu csu haben all die jahre manchmal
gerungen aber am ende zusammen gestanden
der schulterschluss zwischen söder und
laschet kommt spät zu spät finden manche
heute jedenfalls serviert markus söder
dem kanzlerkandidaten fränkische
spezialitäten und verbale treueschwüre
das ist genau das richtige denn entgegen
einer alternative links oder bürgerlich
mit links ist er gemeint olaf scholz
unterwegs sind brandenburg der umfragen
anführer beschwört sein momentum ich
freue mich über die unverändert guten
umfragewerte die entsprechende übrigens
der stimmung die ich auf vielen
marktplätzen überall in deutschland
jetzt spüre wenn ich da sprechen kann
und man sieht da ist unverändert
momentum das kann auch noch besser
werden sie wartet noch immer auf ihr
umfragen momentum annalena baerbock ist
angesichts stagnierender werte
vorsichtiger geworden wenn es um ihre
ambitionen aufs kanzleramt geht wir
haben wahlkampf erlebt da geht es auf
und ab und wir sind jetzt auf der
letzten zielgerade wo es darum geht
gerade für einen aufbruch in diesem land
noch einmal deutlich mehr grüne stimmen
zu gewinnen alles ist bereitet für die
letzten kilometer wahlkampf noch acht
tage 23 stunden dann werden aus umfragen
endlich ergebnisse
ja weil mir ist jetzt matthias fornoff
mit neuen zahlen vom politbarometer
guten abend matthias
siegessicher kann da im moment keiner
sein so sieht es aus aber der wahlkampf
der läuft zwar auf hochtouren die zahlen
aber die sind eher stabil im moment wenn
am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre würde die
union wie in der vorwoche bei 22 prozent
ihrem rekordtief die spd weiter mit 25
prozent stärkste partei fd fw fdp elf
linke 6 prozent alle unverändert grüne
16 prozent minus 1 das würde reichen für
eine spd-geführte große koalition und
für mehrere dreierbündnisse ist für die
befragten denn schon klar wer die wahl
gewinnt nein sagen 82 prozent vor vier
jahren zu diesem zeitpunkt fand eine
mehrheit dass das rennen schon gelaufen
war
die berlinerinnen und berliner wählen um
26.000 bundestag sondern auch das
abgeordnetenhaus und auch da wird's
immer spannende auf den letzten metern
prominenteste kandidatin ist die
ehemalige spd familienministerin
franziska giffey ich stehen ihre chancen
aufs bürgermeisteramt naja die
projektion zeigt jedenfalls ein eher
diffuses bild wenn am sonntag wahl wäre
käme die spd auf 21 prozent cdu 17 und
grüne 20 prozent alle drei recht dicht
beieinander es folgen linke mit zwölf
afd
89 fiel zu einer partei alle unter drei
prozent
alle parteien im abgeordnetenhaus werden
von den befragten eher kritisch
beurteilt als regierende bürgermeisterin
wünscht sich eine relative mehrheit
franziska gefalle von der spd zum
regieren bräuchte sie ein dreierbündnis
einsamer noch mecklenburg vorpommern
auch da werden kommenden sonntag in
einer woche bundestag und landtag
gewählt und da muss ich
spd-ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
erstmals auf so einer wahl behaupten ja
und das stimmungsbild da in mecklenburg
vorpommern das zeigt klare verhältnisse
wenn am sonntag wahl wäre würde die spd
mit 38 prozent mit abstand stärkste
partei afg 17 cdu 15 linke 11 prozent
grüne und fdp bei 6 prozent
mehr als zwei drittel der befragten
wollen manuela schwesig als
ministerpräsidentin behalten für das
amtierende bündnis von spd und cdu würde
es auch weiterhin reichen auch für
rot-rot und eine ampel aus spd grünen
und fdp
für alle drei wahlen gilt dass der
anteil der unentschlossenen
wahlberechtigten noch über 30 prozent
liegt bleibt spannend vielen dank
matthias ausführlich sehen sie das
politbarometer später eben heute journal
und schon jetzt gibt's alle zahlen zur
bundestagswahl und auch zu den
landtagswahlen in berlin und
mecklenburg-vorpommern in unserer zdf
heute
nach italien dort erhöht die regierungen
massiv den druck um die korona impfquote
zu steigern
bislang sind in italien 65 prozent der
menschen vollständig geimpft zum
vergleich in deutschland sind es
62,8 jetzt hat rom entschieden ab mitte
oktober müssen alle beschäftigten in
einem grünen pass nachweisen dass sie
entweder geimpft sind oder einen
gültigen test in der tasche haben sonst
drohen strafen andreas postel
was sie in rom von italiens regierung
beschlossen wurde ist nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als die ausdehnung der
pandemie bekämpfung auf die gesamte
arbeitswelt insgesamt 23 millionen
arbeitnehmer innen sind davon betroffen
geimpft genesen oder getestet nur so
geht es in zukunft an den arbeitsplatz
ich bin überzeugt nur so kann das virus
besiegt werden wenn man leben will muss
man es machen sonst kommt man nicht mehr
raus
das könnte die novaks bewegung stärken
die bereits vorher gegen die impfung war
eine echte impfpflicht gibt es in
italien bislang nur für medizinisches
personal und lehrkräfte die regierung
verspricht sich aber nun von der
ausdehnung des greenpeace einen weiteren
schub für die impfkampagne la prima rnd
registrierte und dies aus zwei gründen
erstens um die arbeitsplätze noch
sicherer zu machen weil der green fast
ein instrument der freiheit ist und
zweitens unsere impfkampagne noch
stärker zu machen der la nostra campagna
die matschie nation es drohen
empfindliche geldstrafen von bis zu 1000
euro und sogar eine suspendierung vom
arbeitsplatz ohne lohnfortzahlung die
akzeptierten corona schnelltests sind
nur dann kostenlos wenn sie aus
gesundheitlichen gründen erforderlich
sind nachdem italien als erstes land in
der eu so schwer von der pandemie
getroffen wurde zeichnet sich gerade ein
deutliches wirtschaftswachstum ab doch
dieses wachstum weist noch einige
schwachstellen auf und deshalb ist die
regierung von mario trage hier in rom
fest entschlossen alles zu vermeiden was
den dringend notwendigen aufschwung in
europas drittgrößter volkswirtschaft
noch gefährden könnte die neuen
bestimmungen gelten ab 15 oktober um der
befürchteten vierten corona wille in
italien paroli zu bieten
als ich das corona virus im märz 2020 in
europa ausbreitete entwickelte sich ein
ort zum hotspot
in tirol mehr als 6000 betroffene aus 45
ländern gaben beim österreichischen
verbraucherschutzverein an sich damals
in dem wintersportort infiziert zu haben
heute sei es deshalb erstmals der
österreichische staat auf der
anklagebank wolf christian ullrich der
erste prozess zum skandal
familie eines ein corona verstorbenen
österreichers klagt hätten die behörden
damals keine fehler gemacht wäre
johannes schopf noch am leben die
angehörigen verlangen von der republik
österreich rund 100.000 euro
schmerzensgeld und schadensersatz in dem
prozess geht es um die gerechtigkeit
dass gerechtigkeit erfahren wird und das
einfach fehler zugestanden werden die
die behörden gemacht haben es können
viele noch am lebensalter nicht damit
fast eine ganze reihe von versäumnissen
der behörden hätten dazu geführt dass
der ski zirkus in ischgl anfang märz
2020 zu einem hotspot wurde von wo aus
sich corona in der folge in ganz
nordeuropa verbreitete sagen die kläger
man hat zu spät gewarnt man hat zu spät
zb après ski pass geschlossen und vor
allem man hat viel zu spät die
wintersaison ist beendet die klage
bezieht sich außerdem auf einen auftritt
von bundeskanzler kurz der das
paznauntal kurzerhand unter quarantäne
gestellt hatte diese gebiete werden ab
sofort isoliert
tausende hatten danach überstürzt
versucht der quarantäne zu entfliehen
das chaos habe zusätzliche infektionen
verursacht argumentieren die anwälte so
auch bei johannes schopf der kurz darauf
an corona starb und dessen familie heute
klagt denn wenn man sich nicht
entschuldigt und wenn man nicht
schadenersatz anbietet dann hat man
nichts gelernt und dann kann sich das
jederzeit wiederholen die republik
österreich bestreitet dass überhaupt ein
rechtsanspruch vorliegt statements gab
es keine mit einem urteil rechnet man
erst in mehreren monaten weitere
verfahren sind angekündigt
in deutschland gehen die aktuellen
ansteckungszahlen weiter etwas zurück
das robert koch institut meldet 11.000
22 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
1947 weniger als vergangenen freitag 20
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incident sinkt leicht auf 74,7
527 weitere infizierte mussten seit
gestern ins krankenhaus die
hospitalisierung rate steigt leicht auf
1,8
wir schauen nach russland auf eine
parlamentswahl ohne wirkliche
alternativen bis sonntag sind dort 110
millionen menschen aufgerufen die neue
duma zu wählen an einem klaren sieg der
kreml partei von präsident putin
bestehen kaum zweifel
trotz steigender unzufriedenheit im land
echte oppositionelle sind nicht
zugelassen in haft oder sie werden
anders bekämpft axel sturm
paris wischnewski ist berühmt geworden
in diesem wahlkampf er tritt für die
oppositionelle jabloko-partei in sankt
petersburg an plötzlich erscheinen zwei
weitere kandidaten mit seinem namen auf
dem wahlzettel alle drei sehen sich
ähnlich das netz lacht sich kaputt
spricht von clown boris
ich habe mit einem lächeln reagiert ich
sehe darin eine hohe wertschätzung
meiner arbeit wenn man mich mit solchen
mitteln bekämpft sind meine chancen wohl
nicht schlecht diese wahl findet statt
in einem schwierigen jahr und wer am
ende siegreich sein wird ist absehbar
einiges russland natürlich ich denke
einiges russland gewinnen mir geht es
sehr gut wenn die in der regierung
sitzen kaum jemand zweifelt daran dass
die partei des präsidenten einiges
russland diese wahl für sich entscheidet
der präsident selbst ruft persönlich zum
urnengang auf die wahlbeteiligung auch
für ihn ein wichtiger stimmungstest
oppositions kandidatinnen und kandidaten
waren im vorfeld zu hauf ausgeschlossen
worden es gab repressionen verhaftungen
urteile im laufe des jahres ist die
gesamte opposition vernichtet worden
durch maßnahmen der geheimdienste durch
strafverfahren oder durch inhaftierungen
russland hat sich verändert in diesem
jahr repressionen auch gegen
journalisten künstler menschenrechtler
putin-kritiker alexej nawalny im
gefängnis auf instagram ruft er zur
abstimmung gegen die einiges russland
kandidaten auf seine app mit
wahlempfehlungen ist aus den app stores
entfernt worden auf druck der behörden
für die bundes war weiß die gift für die
bundeswehr war es die gefährlichste
rettungsmission ihrer geschichte die
luftbrücke nach afghanistan motte hat
bundespräsident steinmeier den
beteiligten gedankt und ihrem kommandeur
stellvertretend mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet das
ziel des zweiwöchigen einsatzes war klar
so schnell wie möglich so viele menschen
wie möglich aus kabul retten bei mehr
als 5.000 ist es gelungen über die
ehrung in berlin ines trams
das bundesverdienstkreuz für den
gefährlichsten einsatz die größte
rettungsoperation in der geschichte der
bundeswehr kommandeur alt nimmt es
stellvertretend für den evakuierungs
verband entgegen sie stünden so der
bundespräsident für das beste der
bundeswehr
würdigen ein einsatz
der den beteiligten viel abverlangt hat
mehr als sich die meisten menschen
vorstellen können
es war ein einsatz dessen wohl und wehe
unser ganzes land für zwei wochen in
atem hielt
dieser einsatz war notwendig er hat
menschenleben gerettet eine luftbrücke
überhastet aufgebaut dramatisches ende
von 20 jahren in afghanistan es bleiben
viele fragen auf beim kommandeur warum
nur zerfielen der afghanische staat und
seine armee so schnell fragt er sich
heute ich war vielen im land ich habe
viele sicherheitskräfte mit aufbauen
können und dürfen und stelle natürlich
auch persönliche fragen ja die wo ich
immer noch keine antworten habe auch das
wird mich sicherlich noch umtreiben ein
kampf gegen chaos und verzweiflung und
gegen die uhr mehr als 5000 menschen
konnten die deutschen aus fliegen viele
aber mussten sie zurücklassen im elend
wir haben das getan was wir in der zeit
konnten jeder hat das bestmögliche
geleistet und damit muss man dann am
ende leben können das nicht mehr möglich
war ich selbst und auch die anderen
soldaten wir hatten viele junge soldaten
dabei konnten sich das glaube ich auch
nicht wirklich vorstellen so ging es mir
auch er ist halt unheimlich viel leid
und elend zu sehen und es ist einfach
unvergleichbar eine verdiente ehrung für
kommandeur und truppe die politik aber
muss schmerzhafte fragen beantworten zum
abzug aus afghanistan
es ist das endgültige aus für ein
atommüll-endlager in gorleben das
bundesumweltministerium hat entschieden
das erkundungsbergwerk dort stillzulegen
der grund sind geologische mängel die
entscheidung im niedersächsischen
gorleben hoch radioaktiven atommüll zu
lagern hatte jahrzehntelang zu protesten
geführt der stollen soll nun mit salz
gefüllt werden
das land berlin kauft fast 15.000
wohnungen von den großen unternehmen
deutsche wohnen und wo novia für knapp
zweieinhalb milliarden euro bei einem
teil der wohnungen laufe demnächst die
sozialbindung aus so der senat
mieterinnen und mieter hätten jetzt die
sicherheit dass ihre wohnungen
preisgünstig blieben
endlich kann man mal wieder raus aus der
bude so brachte es hape kerkeling auf
den punkt nach corona pause gab's
gestern abend in köln wieder eine große
gala zur verleihung des deutschen
fernsehpreises
erstmals unter freiem himmel acht von
insgesamt 30 preisen gingen ans zdf
kasten edinger
große freude auf dem roten teppich der
deutsche fernsehpreis ist zurück und die
prominenz freut dass auch das zdf konnte
gestern abend einige trophäen mit nach
hause nehmen polit talker markus lanz
nutzte die auszeichnung in der kategorie
beste information für ein lob an seine
zuschauer sehr komplexe inhalte zum teil
haben nicht dazu geführt dass leute
massenhaft ausgeschaltet haben das hat
für uns der große überraschung und auch
eine wichtige erkenntnis
also glaube dass wir vom fernsehen
zuschauer manchmal unterschätzen für 20
jahre tritt der fernsehgarten moderation
gab es auch einen preis andrea kiewel
fühlte sich geehrt und berauschend
glücklich stolz gerührt überrascht alles
auf einmal in das x einer million jan
böhmermann machte sich auf dem roten
teppich dennoch freute auch er sich über
einen preis für sein zdf-magazin freue
ich bin auch schwarzer adler eine
dokumentation zum thema rassismus im
fußball wurde ausgezeichnet gerald
asamoah nahm den preis stellvertretend
entgegen
immerhin müssen und deshalb bin ich sehr
froh dass man so ein doku gemacht hat um
hat dass die leute wieder anfängt
nachzudenken
wann die globe in 80 tagen um die welt
gewandt auch einen fernsehpreis eine zdf
reportage über die härteste segelregatta
der welt
für einen sichtlich gerührten hape
kerkeling gab es eine auszeichnung fürs
lebenswerk wenn er auch mit seinen 56
jahren noch viel vorhat ständchen und
standing ovations für ihn der deutsche
fernsehpreis ein feierlicher abend der
sich auch als ein plädoyer für
qualitätsfernsehen versteht
freuen wir uns mit und gratulieren allen
kolleginnen und kollegen und gehen jetzt
zur fußball europa league und den
deutschen auftakt werden da gab es ja
gestern abend die spektakuläre partie
zwischen der eintracht und fenerbahce
istanbul mit einer schlussphase wo ist
unter und drüber ging und frankfurts
torwart das 1 1 unentschieden sicherte
mesut özil steht bei seinem ersten
pflichtspiel in deutschland seit
dreieinhalb jahren genau richtig der
deutsche ex nationalspieler macht in der
zehnten minute aus dem abpraller von
frankfurts torwart kevin trapp die
gästeführung für istanbul eintracht
trainer michael schmidt vertritt den
gesperrten oliver glasner und sieht noch
vor der pause den ausgleich philipp
kostet auf neuzugang sam lammers das
erste eintrag tor des niederländers in
der nachspielzeit der partie verursacht
tra pandemie tiere spurs einen elfmeter
den er dann von paypass geschossen
abwehrt medienbericht trifft per
nachschuss läuft aber zu früh in den
strafraum das tor zählt nicht die am
ende hitzige begegnung endet mit einem
remis
bayer leverkusen dagegen konnte in
seinem auftaktspiel gegen ferencvaros
budapest drei punkte einfahren nach der
frühen 1 0-führung der gäste glich excel
palacios in der 37 in einer wilden party
aus und in der 69 minute erzielte
florian wird die leverkusener 2 2 1
führung die die bayer-elf bis zum
schlusspfiff knapp
joah bittere niederlage dagegen für
union in der neuen konferenz liegt bei
slavia prag verloren die berliner mit 1
3 und
grünes licht für den dfb für einen
möglichen wechsel von u21 erfolgscoach
stefan kunst in die türkei das präsidium
des deutschen fußball-bundes beschloss
heute einstimmig den europameister
trainer aus seinem vertrag zu entlassen
sollte er sich mit dem türkischen
verband einigen und neuer trainer der
nationalmannschaft werden
schauen wir mal das wort danke
schicken schauer unterwegs sind erfahren
sie gleich beim wetter von ersten teil
ii marietta slomka freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um 10 und wir freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind ein
schönes wochenende und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schoko nannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter über skandinavien
hat sich ein riesiges hoch etabliert und
fällt dieses tiefe gefangen beide
zusammenschieben die kühle luft vor
allem den norden deutschlands aber im
südwesten kommt deutlich mildere luft an
und so gibt es morgen fast ein sommertag
im südwesten schauen wir auf die nacht
da kommen die vielen wolken aus
nordosten herein und es gibt regen ja
und ja sonst bildet sich nebel nach
südwesten und an den alpen klar dass auf
mit tiefsten temperaturen bis sechs grad
generell in der südhälfte oft
einstellige werte die einzige ausnahme
der südosten mit zehn grad deutlich
milder nach nordosten hin mit 14 grad an
der ostsee morgen im tagesverlauf
weiterhin viele wolken im nordosten
teils regen an der elbe und richtung
erzgebirge ansonsten im süden häufig
sonnenschein und temperaturen bis 24
grad am oberrhein deutlich kühler im
osten mit 15 als 16 grad zb an der
ostsee ja und die nächsten tage am
sonntag vor allem im süden
durchwachsener mit schauern nach norden
viele wolken im westen zeigt sich die
sonne die temperaturen bis 21 grad und
ab montag ist es kühler aber überwiegend
trocken ein schöner abend